WE HAVE FRESH MATERIAL FOR THE
JOE BIDEN COMEDY SEGMENT.
THE DAY AFTER THAT DEBATE ON
WEDNESDAY WE SAW WHAT HAS TO
BE ONE OF THE MOST STUNNING
POLITICAL CONTRA OF ALL TIME.
AS I WAS WATCHING I PUT OUT
THIS TWEET WHILE NANCY PELOSI
WAS YAKKING IT UP WITH HER
PROPHETIC IMPEACHMENT PEN.
IN MY USUAL MEASURED WAY I
CALLED HER A DIVISIVE,
SPITEFUL, HATE FILLED
CHARLATAN VIEWING THAT WAS
OVER THE TOP, LOOK AT WHAT SHE
ACTUALLY SAID.
WHEN HE'S BEEN IMPEACHED, HE'S
BEEN IMPEACHED FOREVER AND
THEY CAN NEVER ERASE THAT.
>> IMPEACHED FOREVER.
THERE IS THE CONTRAST.
AMERICAN SEE WHAT IS GOING
ON.
LOOK WHAT HAPPENED WHEN THE
PRESIDENT AND FIRST LADY
ENTERED THE STADIUM FOR THE
NATIONAL CHAMPIONSHIP GAME
LAST WEEK.
>> THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES.
THAT IS THE SOUND OF AMERICANS
WERE PROUD OF THEIR PRESIDENT
THERE PROUD OF THE SOLEIMANI
STRIKE, THE FIRST TIME THEY'VE
BEEN CONFRONTED BY AMERICANS
FOR 40 YEARS.
THE AND THE FIRST TIME ANY
WESTERN LEADER HAS STOOD UP TO
CHINA.
THIS WEEK THEY SIGNED A PHASE
ONE TRADE DEAL OVER
$30 BILLION IN AGRICULTURE
EXPORTS.
OVER 70 BILLION FOR
MANUFACTURING.
EVEN MORE IMPORTANT,
PROTECTION FOR OUR COMPANY'S
INTELLECTUAL PROPERTY AND A
PLEDGE FROM CHINA TO STOP THE
COMPETITIVE DEVALUATION THAT
PREVIOUSLY GAVE THEM AN UNFAIR
TRADE ADVANTAGE.
NEXT WEEK THE PRESIDENT WILL.
[INAUDIBLE]
WHICH AFFECTS 40% OF OUR
TRADE.
OUR FARMERS WILL BE ABLE TO
SELL MORE ERIE TO CANADA.
PATENTS AND TRADEMARKS WILL BE
BETTER PROTECTED AND THEY SEND
ANTACID NEWS FOR OUR
AUTOWORKERS TO PREVENT THEM
FROM BEING UNDERCUT BY CHEAP
FOREIGN LABOR.
IT IS THE MOST PRO- WORKER
TRADE DEAL IN HISTORY.
A MASSIVE BOOST FOR OUR
ECONOMY THAT WILL CREATE
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF NEW
JOBS.
THEN ON INFRASTRUCTURE, A HUGE
MOVE THAT BARELY GOT COVERED.
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
SWEEPING AWAY THE BUREAUCRACY
LIKE A 12-MILE EXPANSION OF
INTERSTATE 70 IN DENVER TAKING
13 YEARS TO BUILD.
THESE REFORMS WILL SPEED UP
THE CONSTRUCTION OF NEW ROADS
EVERYWHERE, A VITAL MOVE FOR
WORKING AMERICANS BECAUSE
INFRASTRUCTURE BOOST
PRODUCTIVITY AND MORE
PRODUCTIVE WORKERS GET PAID
MORE.
IT COMES ON TOP OF STEPS THE
ADMINISTRATION WAS ALSO
TAKING.
IT HAS HELPED US BECOME NET
OIL EXPORTER WHICH GIVES US A
FREER HAND IN THE MIDDLE
EAST.
YES, THERE'S A STRATEGY HERE,
PEOPLE, AND IT'S WORKING.
THE SAME ON IMMIGRATION.
THAT'S THANKS TO A COHERENT
SET OF ACTIONS INCLUDING THE
NEW.
[INAUDIBLE]
REMEMBER THE PRESIDENTS THREAT
, THE ESTABLISHMENT FREAKED
OUT.
YOU CAN'T DO THAT, THEY SAID,
THAT'S NOT HOW IT WORKS USING
TRADE POLICY FOR IMMIGRATION
OBJECTIVE, BUT IT MAY HAVE
BEEN UNCONVENTIONAL, BUT IT
DID WORK.
MEXICO SENT TROOPS TO THEIR
BORDER AND THE NUMBER OF LOW
WAGE PLUMMETED.
THAT HELPED BOOST JOBS AND
EARNINGS TO THE LOWEST PAID
AMERICAN WORKERS REVERSING
DECADES OF STAGNATION, ANOTHER
SIGN OF A POLICY STRATEGY
THAT'S WORKING, AND ALL THAT
BEFORE THE RECENT COURT
VICTORY ON THE BORDER WALL.
IN HIS REELECTION AD,
PRESIDENT REAGAN SAID IT'S
MORNING IN AMERICA.
IN THIS REELECTION YEAR WE CAN
SAY FOR SURE THAT THE SUN IS
OUT AND SHINING BRIGHT, RECORD
HIGH STOCK MARKET, THE LOWEST
UNEMPLOYMENT IN YEARS.
LOIS AND HISTORY FOR WOMEN,
AFRICAN-AMERICANS, HISPANIC
AMERICANS.
THOSE ARE JUST THE WELL-KNOWN
RESULTS.
LOOK DEEPER.
THERE'S BEEN MORE IN ALMOST
EVERY AGE GROUP.
POLITICIANS GO ON AND ON, BUT
LOOK AT THE ACTUAL RESULTS
BETWEEN 2016 AND 2018, THE
NUMBER OF TAXPAYERS MAKING
BETWEEN HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS AND $200,000 GREW BY
8% WHILE THOSE MAKING LESS
THAN 25000 FELL BY 5%.
WHY IS THIS HAPPENING?
IN PART BECAUSE OF THE TRUMP
POLICY STRATEGY, DIFFERENT
THAN ANYTHING WE'VE SEEN
BEFORE.
HE'S TAKING TRADITIONAL
CONSERVATIVE IDEAS AND
COMBINING THEM WITH NEW
POPULACE ONES, APPOINTING
CONSERVATIVE JUDGES AND
CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM, TAX
CUTS AND PAID FAMILY LEAVE.
PRO-BUSINESS ON REGULATION AND
PRO- WORKER ON TRADE AND
IMMIGRATION.
BUILDING UP OUR MILITARY AND
STANDING UP TO CHINA BUT
THERE'S A PERSONAL ASPECT TO
THIS TO WHICH I RECOGNIZE FROM
MY EXPERIENCE UNLIKE OTHER TV
HOST, I'VE RUN COMPANIES AND
WORKED IN GOVERNMENT AND I
KNOW HOW HARD IT IS TO MAKE
CHANGE HAPPEN.
LAST WEEK I SAID TRUMP WAS
DIFFERENT BECAUSE HE'S NOT
IDEOLOGICAL, HE'S PRAGMATIC.
HE'S A PROBLEM-SOLVING
BUSINESSMAN.
YOU SAW THIS ON DISPLAY ON
THAT CHINA TRADE DEAL.
NOW THIS MAY SEEMED LIKE A
SMALL EXAMPLE, BUT IT
ILLUSTRATES A BIG POINT.
THE PRESIDENT MENTIONED HOW
THERE HADN'T BEEN JULY THE
FOURTH FIREWORKS AT MOUNT
RUSHMORE FOR DECADES.
>> I SAID WE CAN'T HAVE
FIREWORKS BECAUSE OF THE
ENVIRONMENT, YEAH,
ENVIRONMENTAL REASONS.
I SAID WHAT CAN BURN, IT'S
STONE.
IT'S STONE.
SO NOBODY KNEW WHY, THEY JUST
SAID ENVIRONMENTAL REASONS AND
IN ABOUT 15 MINUTES YOU GOT IT
APPROVED AND YOU'LL HAVE YOUR
FIRST BIG FIREWORKS DISPLAY AT
MOUNT RUSHMORE AND I'LL TRY
AND GET OUT THERE IF I CAN.
>> YOU POLITICIANS WOULD JUST
ACCEPT THE ESTABLISHMENT
RIGHT, SORRY YOU CAN'T DO
THAT.
IT'S A TOTALLY DIFFERENT
MINDSET WHEN YOU PUT AN
OUTSIDER IN THE OVAL OFFICE.
THAT WILL BRING RESULTS WHEN
ALL THE REST OF IT.
HERE'S ANOTHER KEY POINT.
HE LOVES BUSINESS.
I'VE NEVER SEEN ANY POLITICIAN
CALL OUT SUCH A LONG LIST BUT
THE PRESIDENT DID LAST WEEK.
>> DAVID OF UPS, UPS IS DOING
VERY WELL.
ADAM SCHIFF OF HONEYWELL, AL
KELLY, THANK YOU.
NANCY FROM FORD, SANJAY OF
MICRON, INCREDIBLE COMPANY.
WHAT A GREAT BRAND JEEP IS.
WHAT A GREAT JOB THEY'VE
DONE.
>> THAT ATTITUDE IS HOW THE
PRESIDENT AND THE FIRST LADY
HAVE CREATE 14 MILLION BY
WORKING WITH THE PRIVATE
SECTOR INSTEAD OF THROUGH
GOVERNMENT BUREAUCRACY.
CRITICS SAY HE JUST WANTS YES
PEOPLE AROUND HIM BUT LOOK HOW
HE BIT HIS CHINA TEAM STARTING
AS AMBASSADOR.
FORMER IOWA GOVERNOR TERRY
BRANSTAD.
>> I WAS GOING INTO MAKE A
SPEECH BEFORE THE ELECTION AND
HE SAID SIR, PLEASE DON'T SAY
ANYTHING BAD ABOUT CHINA.
IT'S THE FIRST TIME ANYONE
EVER SAID ANYTHING LIKE THAT
AND I SAID WHO IS THIS GUY,
HE'S THE GOVERNOR OF IOWA AND
HE SAID DON'T SAY ANYTHING BAD
ABOUT CHINA SO I HAD TO RIP UP
HALF MY SPEECH.
I SAID WHY.
HE SAID WE DO A LOT OF
BUSINESS.
HIS ATTITUDE THE LITTLE
DIFFERENT THAN OUR TRADE
ADVISOR PETER NAVARRO, RIGHT
PETER, HE'S A LITTLE DIFFERENT
, ALL THIS IS WHY HE'S
DELIVERING AND WHY IMPEACHMENT
IS NOT JUST A JOKE BUT AN
INSULT TO EVERY AMERICAN WHO
HAS A RIGHT TO EXPECT THAT
CONGRESS, LIKE THE PRESIDENT
IS SPENDING ITS TIME "GETTING
REAL" RESULTS FOR WORKERS AND
FAMILY.
OF COURSE YOU CAN FORGET ABOUT
THAT FROM TODAY'S DECADENT
DEMOCRAT BUT THE BEST THING
THE PRESIDENT CAN DO IS FOCUS
ON POLICY, ON RESULTS SO WE
CAN CONTINUE TO SEE A VAST
CONTRAST BETWEEN TRUMP.
[INAUDIBLE]
IF YOU WANT TO GET REGULAR
UPDATES ON POLICY RESULTS,
WERE REVAMPING.
FOLLOW US NOW AT STEVE HILTON
NEXT.
LET'S BRING IN OUR GUEST,
CHARLIE KIRK, AUTHOR OF THE
UPCOMING BOOK, THE ONLY IDEAS
THAT WILL WIN THE FUTURE.
JENNA IS HERE, SHE'S PART OF
THE PRESIDENTS LEGAL TEAM ON
IMPEACHMENT AND NATIONAL
SECURITY ADVISOR AND AUTHOR OF
REVOLUTION, KATIE MCFARLANE.
BY THE WAY, WHERE'S YOUR BOOK
JENNA.
>> IS GOING TO SAY.
I HAVE A BOOK, IT'S CALLED THE
LEGAL BASIS.
[INAUDIBLE]
YOU CAN GET THAT ON AMAZON AND
BARNES & NOBLE.
>> CHARLIE IS GOING TO COMMENT
ON SOMETHING THAT REALLY
SHOCKED ME TODAY.
I'M SHOULDN'T BE SHOCKED THAT
I WAS.
THERE'S A CONTRAST BETWEEN THE
REAL RESULTS IN THE REAL WORLD
AND WHAT THE IMPEACHMENT FUSS
IS ALL ABOUT.
ANY REASONABLE PERSON WOULD AT
LEAST ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
CONTRAST.
THIS MORNING, ON NBC'S
FLAGSHIP SHOW MEET THE PRESS
WITH CHUCK TODD, THEY HAVE A
WHOLE HOUR, LITERALLY NOT ONE
MINUTE ON ANYTHING IN THE REAL
WORLD.
NOTHING ABOUT THIS HISTORIC
TRADE DEAL OR WHAT'S GOING ON,
STUFF THAT ACTUALLY AFFECTS
THEIR VIEW.
I THOUGHT IT WAS COMPLETELY
OUTRAGEOUS.
>> AMERICA IS DIVIDED BUT NOT
THE WAY THE MEDIA WANTS TO
BELIEVE IT.
IT'S DIVIDED BETWEEN A RULING
CLASS THAT IS SO INFATUATED
WITH IMPEACHMENT AND
DESTABILIZING THIS PRESIDENT
AND REVITALIZATION IS
HAPPENING IN THIS COUNTRY.
YOUR OPENING WAS BRILLIANT.
VARIETY OF WAYS.
, BUT MORE THAN ANYTHING ELSE
YUSUF SHOWED THAT THE
PRESIDENT COMES OUT IT WITH
PREGNANT PREGNANT HAS
PREGNANT.PREGNANT HAS
[INAUDIBLE]
THE WISEMEN OF WASHINGTON
D.C., THERE ENTIRE AGENDA HAS
BEEN PROVEN COMPLETELY
INCORRECT.
THEY'VE BEEN GETTING.
[INAUDIBLE]
>> THAT'S THE THING.
THAT'S WHY WANTED TO SET OUT
THE RESULTS.
BACK IN 2016 I THOUGHT WELL,
DONALD TRUMP THE CANDIDATE WAS
LIKELY TO BE BETTER THAN
HILLARY CLINTON ON THE KEY
ISSUE OF WHO'S GOING TO ELECT,
AS TIME HAS GONE ON I'VE
GOTTEN MORE SUPPORTIVE BECAUSE
OF THE RESULTS.
YOU LOOK AT THEM AND YOU THINK
HE'S REALLY DELIVERED.
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT SUPPOSED
TO HAPPEN.
JENNA, I WANT TO PICK YOUR
LEGAL BRAIN ON THIS AND SWITCH
TO THE IMPEACHMENT STORY.
TOO THAT POINT, I WOULD LIKE
YOUR LEGAL OPINION.
CAN SOMEONE SUE PELOSI, THE
DAMAGES.
>> SHE SHOULD BE IMPEACHED.
SHE SHOULD BE REMOVED.
>> SHE WILL, AND IN THE
POLLS.
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT THIS IS
ABOUT.
THE 92nd VERSION OF WHAT'S
GOING ON IN THIS, WE SAW THE
HOUSE MANAGERS FILE THEIR
BRIEF, ESSENTIALLY WHAT THEY
ARE ARGUING IS THAT NO PERSON
IS ABOVE THE LAW, WE ARE PRO-
CONSTITUTION AND PRO RULE OF
LAW.
THE ANSWER TO THAT WHAT THE
PRESIDENT IS ARGUING IS OF
COURSE, THERE IS NOTHING THEY
HAVE ALLEGED THAT IS ACTUALLY
ON THE BOOK AS A LAW THAT HE
HAS BROKEN SO LET'S ACTUALLY
LOOK AT THE CONSTITUTION.
ARTICLE TWO SECTION ONE SAYS
ALL EXECUTIVE POWER IS VESTED
IN THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES.
WHAT THAT MEANS IS FOREIGN
POLICY DECISIONS AND THE
EXECUTIVE AUTHORITY IS VESTED
IN THE PRESIDENT.
THIS IS A POLICY DISPUTE.
WHAT THE DEMOCRATS ARE TRYING
TO DO IS WIELD THE OPPOSITION
POWER IN THE HOUSE AND REQUIRE
A SITTING PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES TO ANSWER FOR
HERS CONSTITUTIONALLY VESTED
POLICY DECISION IN THE CONTEXT
OF THE SENATE IMPEACHMENT
TRIAL THAT IS ABSOLUTELY
UNCONSTITUTIONAL AND VIOLATING
THE RULE OF LAW AND THAT'S WHY
THIS PRESIDENT IS ABSOLUTELY
CORRECT, IT HAS TO BE OUT OF
HAND BECAUSE THERE IS NOT
ABUSE OF POWER, OBSTRUCTION OF
CONGRESS ARE NOT LAWS ON THE
BOOKS THAT HE VIOLATED.
>> THAT'S ROUGHLY COMPLICATED
AND I'VE BEEN THROWN
IMPEACHMENT
IPEACHMENT
IMPACHMENT
IMPEAHMENT
IMPEACHENT
IMPEACHMET
IMPEACHMENT.
>> IT'S SIMPLE, BUT IT'S
COMPLICATED.
I THINK THE DEMOCRATS HAVE
ALREADY LOST, THEY JUST DON'T
REALIZE IT YET BECAUSE THERE'S
THREE POSSIBLE OUTCOMES.
ONE THERE'S A TRIAL IN THE
SENATE, THERE'S A LOT OF
INTERVIEW PEOPLE WHO COME UP
AND TESTIFY.
DO YOU REALLY THINK THEY'RE
GOING TO BEAT DONALD TRUMP IN
THE GREATEST REALITY TV SHOW
OF ALL TIME?
HE CREATED REALITY
TELEVISION.
THE MEDIA WILL GET RICH ON IT,
POLITICIANS WILL GET RICH ON
IT, DONALD TRUMP WILL BEAT
THEM, OR THEY'RE GOING TO
QUICKLY DO AWAY WITH THIS SO
THEY'RE EITHER GOING TO LOOK
INCOMPETENT.
>> JUST RIGHT HERE, WILL HAVE
A LOT MORE LATER ON, BUT BY
THE WAY, WITH YOUR EXPERIENCE,
BY THIS TIME FROM A COUPLE
WEEKS AGO WE WERE BEING TOLD
WE WOULD BE STARTING A WORLD
WAR OVER IRAN.
WE FIX THE AMERICAN ECONOMY,
REBUILD THE MILITARY AND PUT
SANCTIONS ON IRAN AND SQUEEZE
THEM TO THE POINT WHERE THEY
HAVE NO OPTION, THEY DON'T
HAVE A MILITARY OPTION OR AN
ECONOMIC OPTION, AND FORCE
THEM TO COME TO THE
NEGOTIATING TABLE ON OUR
TERMS.
AND IF THEY DON'T.